[Musique
] Pendant toute sa vie, les œufs et sa
famille adoptive ont semé la peur dans le cœur
de leurs voisins au-dessus des rangées de
monstres renards et parce qu'ils étaient un
peu différents, ils passent leurs journées
sous terre et leurs nuits à
fouiller dans les rues à l'abri de la vue humaine.
maintenant quand je détruirai chaque dernier
boxtroll maintenant ma place sur le respect de l'
homme dans cette ville quand leur vie est
menacée si vous nous dissuadez de
nous faire ils trouveront de l'aide
là où ils s'y attendaient le moins si j'accepte de
vous aider vous devez faire exactement  comme je le dis
tout d'abord avec le ballon
allez X les exterminateurs ont commencé par
[Applaudissements]
jamais vu personne faire ça avant allons
les boxtrolls c'est un plaisir de rencontrer
vrai